how much do you really know about the  elusive natasha romanov before i worked  for shield i made a name for myself when  it was time to assemble the avengers who  did shield call let me put you on hold  former kgb assassin agent of shield and  avenger she fought through the battle of  new york  squared off against the winter soldier  defended the world against ultron she  signed the sokovia accords dealt with  all that fallout  and beat back the forces of thanos  when all seemed lost she held the team  together but how well do you really know  her it's time for her story  i've lived a lot of lives  [Music]  you've been waiting for this